real Warriors don't show their hearts
until an ax cuts open their chests
even in the sheath
the sword must be Sharp
so too must the mind and the spirit be
within the body
a person should not agree today
to what he will regret tomorrow
better to fight and fall
than to live without hope
you will reach your destination even
though you travel slowly
life
is not a level field
life is hills and mountains
lowlands and ravines
the era is the result of letting fear
rule your actions
better to Die With Honor
then live with shame
not every cloud which darkens the day
brings rain
when truth and fairness are different
from what is law
better it is to follow truth and
fairness
it is okay that you have made mistakes
life didn't come with instructions
only a coward waits to be taken like a
lamb from the fold
or a fox from a trap
no one is the total fool
if he knows when to hold his tongue
as one candle can light another
so too can greatness of mind be
transferred amongst men
to remain in solitude is to deprive
oneself of this kindling
stand by your own trial
and not by what others say
when a real battle starts
You'll Always Find that there is no
bravest man
where Wolf's ears are
Wolf's teeth are near
that which has a bad beginning
is likely to have a bad ending
the brave man shall fight and win
though dull his blade may be
too much ale and a man's heart is laid
open for all to see
the more folk stand in the way of two
hearts that yearn for each other
the hotter the flame of Love waxes
all the people need in order to rise up
against tyranny
is a leader bold enough to take up the
banner
there is more in honor in accumulating
little by little than in reaching for
the sky and ending up flat on your face
when men meet foes in fight
a stout heart is better than a sharp
sword
oftentimes it is not numbers that wins
the victory
but those who fare forward with the most
vigor
the foolish man thinks he will live
forever if he keeps away from fighting
but old age won't Grant him a truce
even if the spears do
when fear leads the way
the destination is never glorious
even a silent man will be instantly
respected
if he tells the truth
to become a man that instantly commands
respect
don't be afraid to be criticized or
disliked
don't be afraid to engage in conflict
and stand up for what is right
honest conflict is always better than
dishonest Harmony
don't mess with ale if you are weak
a clear head is good company
drinking is a dangerous friend
take care of your speech it can be the
Catalyst for many needless problems
you never know who could be lending an
ear to your ramblings